analytical philosophy was in a sense
founded on sand
[Music]
ra Blackman welcome to how the light
gets in thank you very much
so you're famous for having a theory
about metaphics a theory about what's
exactly moral claims are about
and there's this common perception both
in philosophy I think and perhaps even a
popular perception that if we are to
believe that moral claims like murder is
wrong are objectively true and not sort
of merely the expression of personal
opinion we somehow need to think that
moral facts are part of reality and on
the other hand if it turns out that
moral facts are not in fact part of the
fabric of the world it seems that the
only plausible alternative is that moral
claims are just merely subjective
expressions of personal opinion so you
famously reject that to koshimi can you
explain why and how you go about it well
I certainly try and avoid any
metaphysics so I don't have very much
time for the side of it that you put the
side that would require something like
the will of the universe or God's laws
or something like that
um I I reject that so I am much nearer
to the side which says it's all all a
matter of opinion it's a matter of our
attitudes
uh what I tried to do in my work was uh
explore a middle ground I want to say it
is a matter of our attitudes
but it's not merely a matter of our
attitudes because our our own
um
capacities for Thought enable us to
scrutinize our attitudes and those of
other people
and in a sort of holistic way as without
foundations but with bringing to Bear
other considerations
we can often decide that an attitude was
not justifiable we we reject it
so it's really about the acceptance and
rejection of attitudes including our own
attitudes
so what I wanted to do was defend as it
were the objective is trappings of moral
thought without giving any ground to the
metaphysics that usually goes with those
trappings
does that mean that there aren't really
any moral facts so you know Wittgenstein
famously said in his early work that the
world is the totality of fact so yeah
does that include moral facts it didn't
for Wittgenstein no and um I I think
it's a very powerful intuition that you
know when God created the world he just
had to create the physical world he
didn't have to add or super add a a
layer of morality onto it
um
as to whether there are any moral facts
well that's a tricky one
um it brings this objectivist sounding
baggage or metaphysics
but of course we could answer it by
saying yes here's a moral fact it's a
fact that you shouldn't um uh offer
students different grades for sex that's
a fact it's um
if you disagree with it I'd be very
surprised and rather suspicious of you
um but it's something that's uh
virtually everybody would accept
and so it stands firm um
so if I say do you think Alexis said um
you know it's okay for the
University professors to sell better
grades for sex you'd say no
and you can say no that's not true or
you could say no that's not a fact
which is a fact that you shouldn't do it
um so there's the the language of Truth
and fact has a grip
when we talk about morality and that's
one of the things that people like
myself have to accommodate
or in some extreme cases people say oh
it's all a fiction
um and other people are just skeptical
about the whole business
but if you're serious about life I think
you're serious about ethics
you're serious about morality then you
have to accept that some things stand
firm they they are as it were done and
dusted
in the moral sphere just as much as in
the empirical sphere
and how do we and how do you accommodate
for this talk of moral facts is it just
intersubjective agreement most of us
agree on it therefore it's found no
because we might all be wrong I think we
I think there's no limit to the
possibility of self-criticism I think
self-criticism skids off some cases like
the one I mentioned it skids off that
because I can't think of a criticism to
bring to bear on the idea that it's
wrong for University professors to
uh sell um grade better grades for for
sex
um so I can't imagine really a serious
debate about it
so in that sense debate has stopped but
that's true if we talk about whether
we're in a tent I mean if if I had to
try and prove to you that we're in a
tent
I wouldn't know where to start because
nothing is more obvious than they were
in a tent
um if you started to worry about it I'd
start to worry about your mental health
or your capacities
so so I think that in the moral sphere
just as much as in the empirical sphere
there are views that stand fast
and then we use the language of Truth
and fact
um Peter strawson was philosopher
once postulated that you talk about true
it's often a way of saying ditto
so if I say but you know you shouldn't
do this after the other
you could say that's true or you could
say ditto meaning it goes for me or I'll
copy that I think Americans actually
have a phrase copy that meaning roughly
I agree or I judge that to be true
you mentioned earlier that this is the
sort of self-criticism is always open
open-ended is that is that a kind of
pragmatist commitment do you see
yourself aligned with yes tradition I do
I think it's very important that people
cultivate a sense of self-awareness and
a self sense of possibility of
self-criticism
uh one of the disappointing things about
the modern
world of uh tweets and you know Facebook
and Instagram and so on is that people
come up with certainties too quickly
um because then there's you know where
the certainties according to Trump and
the certainties according to other
people
but each side claims certainty and I
think people are far too quick to do
that and what about
cases of extreme moral disagreements at
the moment there's this kind of debate
being reanimated in the United States of
abortion for example
how do we in the absence of sort of hard
moral facts that we can kind of help us
guide our decision in the same way that
maybe you know being in the tent is kind
of maybe you can point to something and
say well here it is yeah yeah it doesn't
seem to be an equivalent case in in the
moral facts so how do we adjudicate when
it's well disagreement of that level of
course that's where you get hard cases
and I think the abortion case
um I have a definite view about it but I
think that it's a contestable a sensibly
contestable that is people who hold the
other view are not out to lunch they've
got a point and negotiating the point is
very difficult the point for example if
I'm liberal about abortion as I am
I've got to recognize that people are
going to say that the processes of
development of life
are continuous there's no cut off points
um the zygote starts off as a cell which
I think you have to be
really quite outrageous to say is a
living human being it's not any more
than an acorn as an oak tree
but the process of becoming a living
human being is then continuous
and the problem with abortion law is it
will need to find a cut-off point
and people say well you know we can't
find a cut-off point so we better say
it's a human being from the get-go or
we're both not saying it to say to human
being until it's born
and neither of those seems comfortable
but I think people forget that we can
all often find cut-off points certainly
in law
when processes are continuous the
process of driving ever more Dangerously
is continuous across increases of speed
but we say 30 miles an hour or whatever
it might be
and you can go that far and no further
so it's quite possible to make sensible
laws
inside
the apparent
continuity of the process
and I think that's that's how I would
look at the abortion debate
in answering this you said well I
recognize that there's a different angle
on this there's a different argument
it's almost
uh like saying well I recognize there
are different perspectives on this
matter and of course a lot of
philosophers may be starting with nature
sort of argued that this is the case
with
not only moral facts but with everything
you know we only have these kind of
perspectival views on the world there's
no one objective truth as aware that we
can all access so how do we if we
recognize that if we say well there are
different perspectives on this moral
matter how do we adjudicate between
those perspectives how do we know which
ones are better what I'm saying well
well often we're not required to
adjudicate between them because that
that presents us as if we're Outsiders
looking at two
um things whereas in fact we've got an
inside position
um you will come with a certain amount
of moral baggage to the abortion debate
say and somebody else may come with some
slightly different moral baggage but
your ritual you're involved
and so you don't have to choose between
two positions
what you often do is try to persuade
somebody of your position
or try to persuade yourself that your
position is the defensible one or the
better defensible one
um so you you you could hear two voices
within yourself
and then you have to
um you know sort it out you have to not
plump for one or the other but try to
choose one or the other
in the light of your best thoughts the
best thoughts you can Master that's all
you've got all you ever have but having
recognized that even if we can't somehow
come outside of our skin as it were and
look at the different perspectives from
a third point of view even if we
recognize that we can only occupy a
perspective and we can somehow come
outside it and adjudicate between
different ones doesn't that already
water down the notion of objectivity can
we really still hold on to it if we
recognize that well our view in the
world is is a perspective it's not an
objective view I think views become
opinions become objective
um not because they escape perspective
but because
people can come to coordinate on them
and agree with them
so think of an example
um suppose you're accused of a crime
well now you want the police investigate
yo let's say a cues falsely of a crime
you didn't commit it
you want the police investigation to be
objective enough
to discover that you didn't committed
um now it could be a very flaccid
investigation carelessly conducted the
police aren't curious about the evidence
there's all sorts of flaws and failures
possible
please come then turn around and say oh
that's just that was just a different
perspective
you say no you're not doing your stuff
properly you're not investigating in the
way that this problem demands and I
think often we don't think in the way
that moral problems demand we don't take
into account
all the pluses and minuses
um there are examples in the history of
philosophy I think for example the
utilitarians John Stewart Mill Jeremy
Bentham Cedric various others
I think they thought that they were
advancing a very objective very
defensible morality
um but in fact if they thought more
carefully
I think they might have realized that it
required a lot more thought a lot more
um you know repair than they realized
um for example reconciling the the the
task of promoting utility
with the necessity for justice in your
dealings with other people they didn't
really see that as as difficult as I
think it is
so it's very easy to to think oh I've
got the answers here when in fact you
don't but it's not just a matter of
different perspective it's a matter of
doing better
what you said there at the very
beginning of your answer that somehow
the aim is objectivity through agreement
reminded me of Richard rorty who claimed
that solidarity is is the aim here right
so true solidarity and kind of social
agreement over this kind of idea of
objective truth however you have
disagreements so where do you part uh
you're right I I misspoke myself there
um
it's the aim is I mean social solidarity
is good and it is certainly one of our
aims very often so when we are
discussing a moral issue like abortion
uh I I you know I'd be very pleased if
we come out agreeing about whatever
we do agree on the Spectrum
um
but I don't think that's the be all and
end-all that bajrati did
um it's not that there's a beacon of
Truth somewhere God's truth the universe
is truth that we might worry about but
we might worry about whether we've all
done our stuff properly or whether we're
living in some kind of Fool's Paradise
that we've all been misled by some
aspect of our culture our history
um we're familiar enough with those sort
of distortions
I mean looking back for example on
racism the amount there was even when I
was young in Britain is quite different
from the amount that's as it were
tolerable today
I think that's a progress
and I'm glad it's gone that way
and I look back at these sort of as it
were racial miasma that covered us
50 70 years ago
with with a certain amount of you know
shame and guilt
so does that mean that we're talking
about solidarity not only with our
current Community but unimagined future
community that has carried on as it were
the self-critique and self-examination
yes I think that's right
um we're familiar with that in sort of
um more everyday context I mean suppose
uh you and I might say go to the
National Gallery and look at pictures or
we listen to a concert and we agree that
was really very good or we would make
various value judgments
now we're probably aware that we are
both amateurs in which are one of those
all of those uh areas and we're aware
that there may be people worth talking
to and worth listening from
um people who might uh upset our
judgment to say well actually it wasn't
pretty good there was a you know she was
singing flat or
um
uh you think that Renoir is a great
painter but actually when you look at
Cezanne he starts to seem a bit
chocolate box and sentimental
um and we say oh I hadn't looked at
Suzanne thank you for warning me and and
maybe you go out to the gallery with the
better or what you would regard and I
think regard with Justice
as a better appreciation of the thing
where do you exactly part ways with
roshi do you think royalty places too
much an emphasis on solidarity with
one's current community and less so with
the future one yes
um I say that with some
uh I mean that's certainly been my
opinion for a long time
um I'd really ought to re-read Roti to
see whether there are uh cracks in his
edifice at that point because you'd
imagine given his sort of influences
from Dewey and other pragmatists that he
would still perish that he would also
have an element of projecting into the
future and yes never thinking okay we've
arrived at the final truth that it's
always an open process that's right
that's exactly Percy's view about the
process of processes of inquiry and Roti
did present himself as a pragmatist in
that tradition does this approach of how
you think about moral truths or moral
facts or moral claims does it apply to
facts about science physics geography or
those claims less philosophically
problematic do you think well this is a
this is where there is a rift in the
pragmatist loot there are pragmatists
who price
is probably the best known who price
some Bob Brandon
who are more extreme and more Universal
pragmatists
um I myself started off quite a local
pragmatist
in the sense that I would say one thing
about ethics
and either say nothing or say something
different about empirical
judgments I think subsequent work
which I very much admire and accept
has suggested that that's not an easy
division to make
you can see how it comes Under Pressure
if you think of things like modal
judgments judgments of necessity or
judgments about
uh counterfactuals what would have
happened if something or other
it's quite easy to give a sort of
pragmatist story about those
very akin to the one I give about ethics
um Gilbert rail was a pragmatist who
um talking about if then and if such and
such had happened such something else
would have happened or if something
happens something else must happen
he saw those as licensing inferential
licenses inference tickets he called
them
that is you say those things and if
somebody agrees with them you expect
them to make the appropriate inference
I suppose I say uh
uh you know Little Johnny's crawling
around the floor and I say look if he
puts his finger in that electrical
outlet
is going to get a very nasty shock
um I said oh gosh yes
um
I'd expect her then to draw the right
inference and perhaps the inference
would imply since we don't want him to
get a nasty shark we won't don't want
him to crawl around the floor
um
and uh the the role of conditionals
counterfactuals judgments of necessity
in licensing inferences
um is a very powerful point in
pragmatism because those sort of
counterfactuals are involved in all our
judgments you know if you judge that
there's a chair over there
you will accept that if you were to try
to walk through it you
meets an obstacle good fail
um if you were to sit down you'd have a
comfortable support they'll say all
sorts of things follow from the Judgment
that there's a chair there
so no judgment is complete in and of
itself it's just a nugget of fact
which is the is um independent of other
facts
so I think there's the you know
um so there's an opening for holism
there's an opening for holism here yes
exactly
and I think that holism is uh is right
actually
um I think the uh
um uh Russell once said that
um Bradley saw the world as a pot of
treacle whereas he and more saw it as a
heap of shot
um where everything is independent and
separable
um and I think that if that's the
correct metaphor then Bradley was nearer
the truth than Russell right yeah I was
going to ask you because that that was
almost a kind of founding Assumption of
analytic philosophy and Russell and more
of this kind of individualism yes you
know we can examine things and almost
anatomism that we can examine things
separate from everything else and that
somehow tells us yes the truth about
them yes that's right
um and of course it was at one point
called logical atomism the atomism of
the tractatus and uh of Russell's work
in the 19
19 teens since 1915 and said about
around them so yes it was logical
atomism and I think it's been pretty
much exploded
over the past years you've also written
quite a lot about truth and I remember
you started writing about it before this
whole kind of era of post-truth yes I
did it dawned on us I did yes what what
had motivated you at the time was it
did you feel there was about to be a
shift in politics was it a pure
philosophical interest that Drew you to
the question I think it started as a
pure philosophical issue I was
interested in
um especially some of the things that uh
the Cambridge philosopher Frank Ramsey a
young genius who died very young
um had said about truth and some of the
things Fraga said about truth in uh is
Essie the thought
um
so that was a purely academic interest
but as the last Millennium rooted close
of course the the
um
uh very skeptical kind of ism
post-modernism took hold
and that's uh and for example the work
of Richard Roti and promoting that
um annoyed me I think thought we had to
do better than this
um so I Revisited truth then and in 2005
I wrote one book about truth and then
more recently another smaller one
um
yeah it's always been a real interest of
mine I mean it's a peculiar interest
because of course uh I tend to think
there's nothing to say about it but
that's a longer longer story
what do you see as the biggest
philosophical question that still hasn't
received a satisfactory enough account
and one that contemporary philosophers
should be focusing on
that's a very good question
um I think that
um
there are there's
I think there's too much focus on the
philosophy of mind and Consciousness and
all that
the so-called hard problem of
consciousness
um I think that's a problem that
deserves dissolution
um so my instinct is always to write to
me to try to make philosophy easy but
that does involve sort of dismantling
some very hard questions
and so what I'd like to see is more
skepticism in the philosophy
philosophical profession
both about alleged hard problems
and about the methods that are necessary
to tackle them you mentioned earlier on
analytical philosophy was in a sense
founded on sand
and
yet people still behave as if it's the
be all and endors if it's the only
philosophy in town
and I think that ought to change there
is a there is a nice uh eclecticism
come onto the scene people now read
Nietzsche with pleasure some people I
think read Hegel with pleasure which is
much more amazing to me
um and I think there's a plurality of
voices in The Academy which I welcome
so do you think we're entering a sort of
post-analytic philosophy era as aware
when we would leave behind the
certainties of the 20th century and yes
try and find our feet again in some
other way I think it I think we we have
I think a sensible pragmatism is
now one of the principal movements in
philosophy and I'm very pleased to be
involved with it
Simon Blackburn thank you very much
thank you very much
more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV